the traditional process of brick making
in afghanistan has been in place for
hundreds of years
clay is turned to mud which is then
hardened and then molded into bricks
yasa should be in school but he's in
this factory with his brothers and
cousins because his family of 12 needs
him to work
the u.n says 88 of families in the
country have at least one child between
the ages of 11 and 17 working in
difficult conditions
yasir says he has little choice as his
family's quality of life has worsened
rapidly
in the past year our lives have changed
now we can't buy clothes for our
families we cannot even eat proper food
there are sixteen hundred brick making
factories in the day subs area of kabul
alone
but the country's economic crisis means
there aren't many buyers for their
product
as coal becomes expensive the owners
here do not raise the price of the
bricks but rather cut down the wages the
workforce most of it coming from eastern
afghanistan only works during the summer
and struggles to find jobs through the
rest of the year
the workers get about three dollars to
make a thousand bricks although fewer
kilns are operating now
i worked for three months on a dairy
farm in nangarhar but a disease outbreak
ended the work now i've moved here to
make bricks
the taliban which calls itself the
islamic camera it says it understands
the problem but the options are child
labor or starvation
if the islamic emirate of afghanistan
would have the power and capacity we
would never let any child work but the
problem is that first we are in a bad
economic situation and secondly the
families of these children are poor and
helpless
the taliban says it's trying to revive
the economy and it's appealing for
international help
one person from one family can feed
around 20 people if they are employed if
countries want to help use the human
resource of afghanistan provide
employment opportunities
but until such options can be found many
afghan children and adults like these
will have to go on baking bricks to
survive swamiji al jazeera kabul